I'm quite optimistic I think that we
have the opportunity to really shape the
planet in the next hundred years in ways
that are really really good and
beneficial there's some huge problems
that we have to deal with you know the
the you know if we understand that the
root cause of terrorism is is
frustration with with poverty and no
hope and tyranny in various places in
that that we need to think about how we
arrange our affairs to help these very
very tragic places to become you know
reasonable places for people to live and
I think we have no choice we're going to
do that it's just a matter of how
bumbling we are at it along the way so
then I'm very hopeful to imagine you
know a time in a hundred years from now
when you know Ethiopia is is prospering
with it with a middle class and you know
people doing the simple thing that
people want to do everywhere which to me
what most people want out of life is
they want to go to work they want to
have a decent job they want to make a
decent amount of money they want to come
home and play with their kids and that
the extremism we see in various places
on the world is really not natural it's
certainly not inevitable and something
that we can do something about in the
long run and I'm reasonably optimistic
about that of course I have some some
concerns about bad things that may
happen certainly when we have you know
irrational tyrannical governments
working very very diligently to get
their hands on nuclear weapons it's got
to scare you it's got to scare all of us
that the the Iranians have a missile
that can reach Munich and they're
working as far as anybody can tell quite
diligently to get nuclear weapons who
knows i don't know how to solve that
problem but i do know that it doesn't do
the world a lot of good to think about
people like that with
their values in control of incredibly
dangerous weapons and that's the kind of
thing that I think it could really
derail human progress in the next
century but I'm optimist so I don't
think it's going to come to that I think
you know one of the things that we have
to remember is that nuclear weapons are
a World War two ERA technology right
this is not rocket science anymore it's
something that that can be built will be
built but that at least so far as
societies have come to the point of
having those tools available there's
enough moral people enough ethical
people everywhere in the world who
realize like using this would not be a
good idea that it doesn't further
anything valuable and you know that's
not to say it's never going to happen
but it is to say that I'm reasonably
optimistic that people everywhere people
understand that a nuclear holocaust is a
very bad thing and that we should try to
avoid that at all costs and so I would
expect to see you know really mass
public demonstrations and really mass
strikes to prevent some of these things
from happening they can break down to it